Je veux commencer par la très bonne nouvelle que nous
réparer aujourd'hui ce
3 vaccins enregistrés
coffee wak et centre de noms développé
Chumakov et déjà à la mi-mars le premier
cent vingt mille doses seront lancées
chiffre d'affaires civil aujourd'hui la russie
le seul pays qui a déjà 3
vaccins pour la prophylaxie
système de régulation des infections selon notre
la moyenne est arrivée à la conclusion qu'il est possible
ces premiers résultats
enregistrer un vaccin parce qu'ils
fuyez les noix ce sera un canular
l'efficacité logique et donc
appelé c'est ainsi que le vaccin
affecte le système immunitaire et nous avons vu
que dans un pourcentage significatif quelque part
environ 85 87 pour cent
les volontaires se gagnent le 28 au bourreau
ont des retardateurs de flamme et des réponses
la tolérance se produit dans la première phase
il vient de passer dans la première phase
environ 200 bénévoles et
la portabilité est très bien nous n'avons pas
presque pas de complications
[la musique]